my name is Alice
killing
this has been my whole life
we're here today to talk about our
destiny we're here to talk about the end
of the world everything has led to this
I can't run anymore and 48 hours
humanity will be no more there is a way
to end all this why should I trust you I
cannot do something you are very much
revenge
umbrella developed cure and airborne
antivirus gets in the hive it's our only
chance now something that's nothing big
oh my god that's an army of Fame in our
way what are we gonna do we're gonna
kill every last one of them
dyma
I killed your Washington
yeah big mistake
all this could end
stop umbrella whatever it takes
something stuck in us are you sure this
is what I do
I can't remember much before all this
started sometimes I feel like this been
my whole life right knee
killing
my name is Hollis and this is my story
the end of my story ten years ago in
Raccoon City there was an outbreak
and spread across the world within days
one way or another our world is coming
to an end
the question is what we end with it
imperat developed an airborne antivirus
it would destroy the t-virus
I have no reason to believe a word you
say true but I can obviously you want
very much revenge I have to get to the
hive we go together we're gonna kill
every last one of them
and grab some gear
this is what I do
we played a long day you and I
but now itself
Attis what do you want from me
humanity will cease to exist unless you
return to the hall
I trust you behind you
everything's led to this
what we're gonna do we're gonna kill
every last one of them
the prodigal daughter returns
Washington yeah big mistake